hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play fovea 1.5 now
this is the unofficial sequel because
the sequel is still in development
- phobia which is a game that I played a
long time ago that I wasn't a huge fan
of it had its moments but it just wasn't
all together but now the developers
reimagined either the first game or an
entirely different concept into another
game and according to another youtuber
by the name of red wolf gamer this is
much better than the original and I
should play it by the way red wolf gamer
is a great youtuber if you haven't heard
of him I've done a few videos with him
in the past um just in collabs
I'll check him out he's like he's really
talented and really funny but he just
doesn't get the attention he deserves so
his links in the description go ahead
and check him out he really really good
tell you what let's get into it oh there
we go
okay it all began in a rather abnormal
day I had been driving for hours with
still a couple more left on to my
destination being unfamiliar with the
area I took a wrong turn somewhere which
led me to drive for hours in a narrow
road with no turning spots
eventually running out of gas I set on
foot and started to look for shelter
from the cold the road seemed to go on
forever with no sign of life anywhere
within miles finally reaching the end of
the road cold and exhausted I saw a roof
on a house appearing in from the behind
the trees it was a mansion it looked
like the place hadn't been touched for
decades oh I'm sure it'll be filled it's
delightful
non monstrosity when I opened the front
door my suspicions of the place being
abandoned was confirmed disappointed for
not getting the help I was looking for
but also relieved to get help shelter
from the freezing wind I stepped in no
no don't it's a mistake they'll eat your
butt alive okay so this seems kind of
familiar from the first one but once
again this is a remaking totally
different ID hey wait a minute I
remember that that was from the first
one that was the art on the title page
of the first one do I have uh I don't
have a flashlight or anything it's
awfully dark in here okay so if I'm
thinking back with my intelligent brain
Oh Tron I remember that there was a
layout of multiple levels of an addict
in a basement and all sorts of different
things this artistic and delightful I
love how this game is in pastels it's
stuck however it seems weakened I could
probably pry it up one of the tools some
kind you mean mom muscles I think I just
called myself a giant pool there but
everyone ignore that I'm I like it it
looks much better than the first one
actually
oh this is just the world's creepiest
floor right here what is that the box of
matches can i light it can i light it
can i light it pressing lots of buttons
here doing a bit of a samba but I'm not
lighting anything okay
okay close that it's too dark to see
anything I better not go wandering out
there without any light what there's a
little cloud there one of the control
said thoughts okay most of the house is
too dark to explore I need to find a way
to get the power on ah was that a part
of the first one it's been a long time
since I played the first one I think the
first one actually was like and that was
early on in my YouTube incurring well
it's definitely got the creepy factor in
it as the doors are a little shiny
okay so there's got to be something here
that I can open up into a passageway
that lead to the basement because I
believe that the generator is in the
basement
I got admit this actually looks really
good and surprising because if you are
I'm sorry did I step into the closet of
Horrors oh I see
oh I see
why are you doing this to me that's not
nice
I don't want to go down here now I
didn't want to go down here before there
we go well I didn't know that the choir
of demonic demons was gonna be playing
its concert down here King louder shut
up oh you're really creepy it's creeping
me out man Zubin me out
keypad I wonder what it's for I don't
have the combination though seems like a
really modern mansion to be abandoned
for decade I'm sorry really is there
something down here that I should know
about I'd really like to know seems like
from the other side how was that
possible this also seems to be scratch
marks on the door oh okay that was the
okay a power switch foot chunk
loading it did that before I remember
it's so creepy
I don't know no yeah no that's actually
really good I really like that sequence
it was fantastic the atmosphere was
great
Oh what are the things that a lot of war
games forget and one of the things that
I really enjoy is when a horror game
forces you to do something that you
don't want to do that's one of the
moments like you don't want to go in the
basement Oh blading but I'm sure nothing
bad will happen it was this actually
open okay oh is it like an elevator a
dumbwaiter or something like that
probably no seems like the choir of
demons took its leave and went a little
farther away but either way I got the
lights on huzzah oh it's getting louder
again why why choir of demons choir
basement demons basement what stammers
Oh demons no demons diamond no demons
here we go okay demons no demons I had a
thought it's starting to get cold I
should look around the house and see if
I can warm up the place how with my love
you mean okay so I'm not gonna go
upstairs just yet because I'm gonna need
to explore all of the basement floor
it's locked - it down
an ass that music also sounds pretty
familiar do I know that from somewhere
oh that's where the matches find a nun
that was another way around I wouldn't
gone
Todd damn it that door came at me quick
okay yeah I'm starting to recognize this
this is actually kind of the same layout
as in the game I played before so there
should be things if I recall that are of
similarity okay so I'm guessing I don't
want to leave there's no point wandering
out there in the cold I'm lucky enough
to have this place of shelter as it is
hello mister man I remember you okay I
guess I gotta go upstairs now I think
there must be something I don't have the
tool to open that so I got to go up the
stairs where was up the stairs was over
here right here over here yeah okay oh
we're making progress
some diabolical demon up here won't
budge
I don't remember on the monsters came
out I know there are I know there are
monsters oh that's just a toilet nothing
to be afraid of a note I might be
getting paranoid I even stalled a word
locked to the tool cabinet I feel like
I'm too careful sometimes which might
just be a good thing considering the
importance of my work I just need to
remember the password well what a word
you wanna call me mad'line divulge your
secrets to me the stranger who barged
his way into your house and now is in
the process of ransacking everything
okay oh by the way I don't know if I
actually mentioned it but this game is
made on the FPS creator engineer and
surprisingly it looks really good for
being made on that and hi you look much
creepier when I looked at you sideways
through my eyeballs
okay before number 27 August waves of
1967 moving to this house was for the
best of the experiment I have done a lot
of progress ever since the place is
perfectly in the middle of nowhere I
love discussions or any curious eyes
though it gets a little lonely out here
from time to time but the experiment is
too important for such minor emotions
really minor emotions of loneliness ha
got you what do you go to ok must be one
of the many locked doors throughout the
house yes yeah Oh God yeah that there's
like dust hanging in the air I was like
what the hell is that you know a lot of
people are in the comments I read the
comments and you're like huh huh you
didn't actually see anything you're just
stupid you're barren no when I say did I
see something I really saw something ok
a bet wait is this something I'm there
how do I crouch I came another note
parivar fortitude the mixture seems to
be too powerful for the rats I'll have
to find something bigger as a test
subject the mixer still lacks a few
ingredients and I'm running out of
budget funds I feel like I'm getting
somewhere with my experiment and it's
too important to be dropped because of
this I'll have to think about something
what are you spending money on you're
out here alone in the middle of nowhere
who's gonna take your money who's gonna
make deliveries to your creepy mansion
in the middle of nowhere
who even knows about it ok so what was
the point of that there must have been
something in here that I needed right oh
space to crouch well I don't make a ding
dong damn bit of sense but whatever ok
space Crouch I guess all right I'll take
it take it I'll play a game
I don't see anything I really don't all
right let's move on maybe that was like
the key to all squeeze somebody
squeaking around is it just me being
paranoid
hey I know I remember there was like one
buck shelf that could been moved before
one budge oh wait did I go this way oh
there's no this way never mind
aha I see you now panic [ __ ] I know
what you is okay those blood on the
walls
nevermind Wow damn it there must have
been something in that room what though
okay there must have been something in
the rumor that I could have gotten or
something like um maybe uh a bit of odd
tool of some sort there's another sort
of tool that I can use like that
gigantic knife that would love to have
for safety reasons there's got to be
something else that I'm missing
something obvious okay I remember that
these stores were blocked off for some
reason like you would say hey good yeah
baby
all right it's getting late and I'm
tired from driving the whole day I
should look for a bed to sleep in no no
I kind of forgot what my actual
objective was which was to find a place
to heat up so I forgot about that but I
explored a bit that was important yes
let's go take a nappy nap we're gonna
free the old house in two what bad could
happen
mysterious doors locked from the inside
ain't gonna be nothing weird flying long
a doors you're no Rama I'm so tired
oh loading
an area oh good oh good oh good oh good
for you
a no way no I've already I think I I
think I may be encountering to something
bigger was that nice a little is that
hello what is that noise that's what I
asked
don't copy me okay all right you know
what enough lollygagging let's go find
out what it is
come on bring it on what are you go
charging into the deep I'm ready you
ready I'm not I hear you you ready ready
for you the biggest coming from the
basement
the noise stop now could have just been
anything like some animal scratching the
pipes rats in the walls are noises of
the old house whatever it is to stop now
I should try to get them are you sure
it's now down here maybe I should check
seemed like a good idea no okay you're
still locked alright
I swear I can hear noises coming from
behind this door oh I think there might
be a monster shut up creepy creeping me
out man
uber me out you're forgetting alright I
think I'm all out of time for this no
yes yeah I'm all out of time for this
part so before I go to bed and start the
next area I'm gonna cut it here so thank
you all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos it I've done
and as always I will see you in the next
video
anyway I'm still thinking the most time
before circle back to